mother jones which is like
i think it's best described as a
socialist publication i think they're
kind of like that jacobian or whatever
that socialist publication is like
they're the far left of the far left
um they thought haugen was uh going too
soft
the facebook whistleblower doesn't have
the solution revolving door regulations
never make anything better
uh if you believe that facebook is
producing significant harm the solution
that follows
should probably be significant as well
as evan green deputy director of fight
for the future told me rectifying
facebook's invasive privacy practices
could require a privacy law strong
enough to effectively kill facebook's
current business model so they're kind
of jumping the fence like it's not like
90 percent of people aren't having a
you know
decent or good experience on facebook
you know seeing their family's photos
it's a little ridiculous to think about
like doing something as draconian as
shutting down facebook i think
you know the algorithm being more
transparent the studies being
transparent would be the next logical
step here right that is the next logical
step um and there are things you can do
to make things more transparent that
solve problems i'll give facebook some
credit here the facebook ad library if
you just type in facebook ad library um
you can see every ad and the creative
placed on for every different company or
organization they did this for politics
to make sure that people didn't do these
crazy clinton ads again that the
russians were buying to try to create
more strife here in our country on our
original sin racism uh you know
probably the worst part of american
uh america's history i think most people
would agree and uh
this database has now made it
really hard to do
smarmy ads on facebook because it will
be revealed if you're doing something
really crazy on facebook it's right
there in the database you can't place
ads on facebook without them being
public anymore well if that's the case
for ads let's do it for the research
let's make all the research public and
have a town square where we debate it so
if haugen is getting hate from
facebook and pro facebook surrogates and
then
she's getting hate from the
anti-facebook crowd i think that means
her position is pretty uh moderate i
would say and uh senator amy klobuchar
um who i am uh increasingly uh impressed
with i think
you know i don't know her exact politics
but when i see her asking questions she
tends
to uh be well prepared uh it seems and
so
uh here's the democrat from minnesota
and she starts her questioning with an
impassioned statement these things are
also performative um about big tech
lobbyists in dc
and uh this to me was
quite informative 30 seconds see on the
other side we have not done anything to
update our privacy laws in this country
our federal privacy laws nothing zilch
in any major way why because there are
lobbyists around every single corner of
this building that have been hired by
the tech industry we have done nothing
when it comes to making the algorithms
more transparent allowing for the
university research that you referred to
why because facebook and the other tech
companies are throwing a bunch of money
around this town and people are
listening to that
yeah i would love to see her name names
there did she take money from these
lobbyists does the person sitting next
to her taking money from these lobbyists
uh the fact that there's you know
hundreds thousands of folks lobbying and
our privacy is not being protected and
there's not new privacy legislation
when you compare what's happening in
california and in europe
you know privacy is a serious issue we
should have some legislation around that
is there anybody here who wouldn't want
more
privacy regulation so that their
information was
kept more private and not recorded i
don't think anybody listening to this
stream right now in this podcast
wouldn't want to see more privacy
protection um so here she is asking uh
how can about facebook and instagram's
impact on teen girls and body issues
which
this is the reason why i think facebook
has now
um hit a very different moment in time
this this could be the icarus moment uh
for facebook where they just flew a
little too close to the sun it's one
thing
you know to ban trump or not ban trump
uh or to
have russians buying ads you know we can
debate those issues they're super hyper
political but you there's nobody nobody
who wants to see young teen girls have
body issues bulimia anorexia these these
are like the worst things in the world
right like nobody wants
this uh to be
increased in the world and the fact that
now there is a link between instagram
and teen girls anxiety depression
body dysmorphia is pretty damning and
this really does
i think lean people more towards the
cigarette cigarette company analogy uh
or metaphor or in their mind framing
versus the car metaphor that uh mossari
i think the leader of instagram was sort
of pushing so here's 65 seconds from
klobuchar and how again i'll see another
side another major issue that's come out
of this eating disorders
studies have found that eating disorders
actually have the highest mortality rate
of any mental illness
for women and i led a bill on this with
centers capital and baldwin that we
passed into law
and i'm concerned that this algorithms
that they have pushes outrageous content
promoting anorexia and the like i know
it's personal to you
uh do you think that their algorithms
push some of this content to young girls
facebook knows that they're the
engagement based ranking the way that
they pick the content in instagram for
young users for all users
um amplifies preferences and they have
done something called a proact a
proactive incident response where they
take things they've heard for example
like
can you be led by the algorithms to
anorexia content and they have literally
recreated that experiment themselves and
confirmed yes this this happens to
people so facebook knows that they are
that they are leading young users to
anorexia content
yeah so this is the perniciousness of
the algorithm when we build algorithms
here in
the technology industry
you're not really saying here's what i
want the algorithm to interpret the
world that's not really what's happening
it's more outcome based
so you're telling the algorithm you know
run a series of experiments look at all
the data
and
if somebody were to
click on x would they click more if they
click on y or z do they click more okay
after clicking on x if they click on why
do they stay on the service longer it's
just
might is right
the length of your session is what
matters the frequency at which you come
back is what matters we're just looking
at outcomes with these algorithms we're
not looking at the journey
right we're not looking at how you got
there we're looking at
um
where you wound up and if where you
wound up was on youtube the intellectual
dark web or
you know worse um
that's bad right and there was a
specific case uh with ben shapiro and if
you watch ben shapiro's content and
listen he pushes the envelope on being
anti-trans and you know
edgy sort of positioning uh socially
you might then get um
like milo yiannopoulos who went from
being you know like a
kind of a cheeky blogger when i met him
in the 2000s and to being like
straight up like hanging out with white
supremacists you know
and just crazy
all of that kind of
uh algorithmic
shaping of your behavior and leading you
down rabbit holes has been proven over
and over and over again
dela for entrepreneurs wants you to stay
connected to your business no matter
where you are in a world where you can
work from anywhere why would you let
technology hold you back mobile ready
devices such as dell's latitude line of
tablets pair with verizon to give
founders the power to stay connected
wherever there is cell phone service so
you can stay productive as you scale
your business with the confidence of
secure connections no more relying on
public wi-fi which is a disaster because
it's usually way too slow and you're
gonna get hacked it's that simple so
stay confident that your connection is
secure with dell's mobile ready devices
i love my dells i got dell monitors and
computers and laptops everywhere dell is
the greatest thank you so much for
supporting this podcast and for
supporting me for three decades i've
been buying oh my god it's four decades
i've been buying dell since the 80s and
i love them so go to launch dot co slash
dell to get connected to marcus and
manager at dell for entrepreneurs for
more info and to unlock exclusive
discounts like five percent off once
again launch dot co dell to get
connected and save that five percent
today thanks dell